oh man
so where do you see this going in the
future i know we got to wrap up soon
where do you see the future of
scientology going in 20 30
40 years when david's miscavige is
eventually
he dies and moves on someone else is
going to take over what's
what's the future of scientology dim
it's going to continue
to uh decline and erode
with that much money and that much
property it takes a long time for
something like that to go away entirely
i don't think that the subject will ever
totally go away because there will
always be books and people that are like
yeah well you know well we find this
helpful and this and that yeah
but i think that within
the next few years there will be a
revisiting of their tax-exempt status
and when that happens that will
effectively be the end because
the organization can't survive
with any scrutiny of where it's spending
its money
if if scientologists understood and knew
how much of the money they give to
scientology
gets spent to pay
high-priced lawyers private
investigators
smear sites on the internet and all the
other [ __ ] that goes on
there was a lot of them that would just
go i you know
i i can't i can't participate in that
yeah when it's happening
in the sort of abstract they don't
really know
and they don't really have to look and
nobody ever really tells them what's
really going on
then they they remain willfully
ignorant right as soon as
the irs
was required scientology to provide
tax returns and they would have to
report
on where they're spending their money
and what they spend their money on
oh all hell would break loose because
they tell people that
you know you have to give us money for
hurricane
blabla or the tornadoes that just landed
in kansas city
and they tell people all over the world
that they you have to give us money for
this because we're gonna go help
and they may collect 10 million dollars
and they will fly a film crew
and 10 people there and put them in
yellow shirts
have them do a little work do a video of
it and then
send it out and say look here's the
great work that all of our people did
now you need to give us more money so
that we can do more work
if people actually saw how little of the
money
they have given to scientology got spent
on the things that scientology claims it
is spent on
they would stop giving money altogether
wow there's got to be a way that someone
someone
out there is soon going to be able to
prove all this with like hard evidence
you would think it's going to happen
sooner or later yeah i can't believe it
hasn't happened
i keep saying look if you want to do it
the smart way is how the fbi did it in
1977
because scientology keeps incredible
records they keep records
of everything and
you want to prove the case
go get the records yeah wow
well that was uh invigorating two hours
thank you so much for doing that tell
the people listening and watching where
they can watch
and listen to your new podcast and look
at your website
oh well though
danny the podcast is called scientology
fair game
it's on i heart podcast but it's
available on spotify and
apple i mean you can find it anywhere
okay
my blog is called mikerindersblog.org
and then i created a website called
fairgamepodcast.com
which contains documents and links to
each episode of the the fair game
podcast
okay so when they're listening to the
audio version they can go on the website
and look at all the documents that
you're referencing
correct awesome cool mike render thank
you so much for your time
i hope to have you on again in the
future you're very welcome
[Music]
[Laughter]
so